Ahana elements are a bother hi to buddy
degree I'm a mama the word and what
Laura was her I'm bar Maria Novella
I Hungary the octave ability parties are
a beret Rivaldo feed ahora llaman
Hannity ahora de bourree
but Jacare she was it go red Meredith
Buscher planetary body guard you ready
to Montana no let me provide a sort of
are these lemons are a hammer to the
idea first rodeo girl fussing over there
are so many hurry era hana hana no for
yeah
[Music]
Mohammed is stateless he's been here in
the sprawling camp for over a year
he's one of the 120,000 10 to 18 year
olds living in the raw huge refugee camp
at the bangladesh myanmar border his
family fled the bloody military-led
massacre in Myanmar which killed up to
ten thousand people by December 2017 and
for those who made it to the camps
there's a real fear of Ranger youths
becoming a lost generation no one is
allowed officially to work some people
buy and sell food aid supplies but the
risks are high Bangladeshi authorities
say it is a criminal offense yet people
do whatever they can to get fried rice
am i doing Allah Allah yeah so no you
look at Eric Taylor Wedell very very
teeny very high mother hasta la gone and
dialing dial key hi hi hi honey
the bimonthly food rations each family
receives consists of rice lentils and
vegetable oil with few opportunities to
learn and fearful of returning home to
Myanmar Muhammad has taken up whatever
casual work he could find the work is
challenging
thank Allah when the lane and hospital
for studio monitor out I wasn't nowhere
on a house as a mother a house in the
Reno and led to bullying or our
Inglaterra title a demand to do cooper
de l'homme cabrera Huizinga robbers
teyanna loether Aurora Kira - security -
ooh - Deucalion lovely area a like a
fire-eater adhara
they figure on bottom the money that to
come here got humble for it after the
prom with every money net were our
custom made alongside his tours and the
daily grind at the blacksmith workshop
Mohammed is a Tory survived terror and
his memories his scars of war every
burden he continues to carry our
Abdullah failure Hari gotta travel era
Romania he got a terrible fever I will
be Darren Adam oorah
Colonel - Anna hurry where she has to
hide clear Khaleda Zia tiara highest are
higher Giovanni hide Collier - in terror
will show host O'Hara
Muhammad used to collect firewood in
Myanmar and now in the refugee camp in
Bangladesh he supports his parents his
five sisters and two brothers who are
reliant on aid his eldest son his father
looks for casual day work to you and I
after 509 BC I found a hole in every ad
that I wanna know how daddy Margaret
ali-money carretera de ma mama Jota
cheeky bother
do defeat your mother for German
chocolate eater AHA - Cara cerca de do
de de 14 de Hory edenal animals are
valuable
Muhammad works 10 hours a day the long
audience work every morning and evening
and then standing all day to work have
taken a toll on his body
it's a one-owner how a husband you are
they
your money tango Sofia draws on moral
chaos it here
harder harder in any money they were the
corpora Helene Caravaggio young tomorrow
David I forgive us our alumni Europe
this is superior while his features
uncertain Mohammed still dreams of a
life waking go to school come on it's
cool for aqui para esta manera de Guerra
after name one of us your ma mama
hospital when I got there I have to
however in my area the door earlier a
success attend another another thwarted
but for now Muhammad is restreaming of
the day when he'll be able to go home
you are there a single gotta be careful
about everything Murata Mura Deripaska
Sarika Bashar ii-era essaouira Cecilia
for the wonderpana powerful arsenal in
Hyderabad - ELISA are so Morris event
horizon the Varma's in the ratio
you
[Music]